Google just released their best and most
performant AI model, Gemini 3.1 Pro, and
this is incredibly powerful all across
the board. So, in this video, I'm going
to go over how and where to use it, some
cool stuff it can do, and of course,
we're going to review its specs,
performance, and benchmarks compared
with other models. Let's jump right in.
Thanks to HubSpot for sponsoring this
video. All right. Now, at the time of
this recording, 3.1 should already be
available in the Gemini app. So, if you
select Pro, notice that it says it uses
3.1 Pro over here. So, let's try out a
few prompts. First, let's test out its
creativity and generating new ideas. So,
I'm going to get it to develop an OS for
mobile that's even better than Android
or iOS. Include eight apps on the home
screen. Explain what you designed, how
things work, and your rationale behind
it. And then under tools, I'm going to
select canvas so that we can preview
what it built in a side window. Let's
press run. All right. So, here's what it
built. It's called Fluid OS. Here are
the eight core apps of this OS. So,
there's this omni or top banner, which
is the brain of the phone. I guess it's
this one over here. So, if I click into
it, it's basically your unified AI
agent. It reads your calendar, emails,
location proactively, displaying exactly
what you need to know right now, such as
when your next meeting is. And then the
next one is thread. This is where it
unifies all your messages, emails and
DMs and calls in one place. So here it
says why have separate apps for SMS,
WhatsApp and email thread unifies all
your communications. And then next we
have the sense app which aggregates all
your biometric data from your
smartwatch, phone sensors, etc. And then
we also have flow which is like a
universal media player. And then we also
have prism which I guess is this one. So
this is not just a camera but an AR lens
for real-time translation, text copying,
visual search. And then we have shift
which is this one which is navigation.
So this is like Google maps I guess but
it knows when you leave for work and
proactively shows the traffic delay
without you asking. And then we also
have this vault icon which I guess is
for security and keys, credit cards,
passwords. And then we have this home
icon which is for controlling your smart
home. Now there's no correct answer to
this. This is just what it designed, but
let me know how good this is. Do you
think it's better than Android or iOS?
All right, here's another one of my
standard tests. So, I'm going to upload
this image and let's get it to create a
beautiful 3D animation from this image.
Let's see how good it is at coding this
up. All right, and here is what I got.
This pigota actually looks really nice
and detailed compared to other models.
I've been testing out this prompt with
all the other top models and by far
Gemini 3.1 generates the most detailed
version of this pagota so far. Now, it's
not perfect. It's still lacking like the
rails and the windows and the roof tiles
plus, you know, the cherry blossoms
could look more detailed, but just from
one prompt, this is already very good.
In fact, Gemini 3.1 Pro is way better at
3D and spatial understanding. So, here
are some additional 3D generations from
Gemini 3.1 Pro versus the previous
Gemini 3. And as you can see for all
these examples, it's way more detailed
and better quality. If you get it to
create some SVG animations of different
things, you can see that Gemini 3 Pro
does these a lot better. Everything just
looks a lot smoother and more detailed
and more accurate compared to the
previous version. All right, next let's
see how good it is at composing music.
But first, we need to make an interface
for it to create the music. So, first,
let's get it to make a piano roll
interface where I can drag and draw
notes on the timeline. Let's press run.
All right. So, here's what I got at
first. Let's play this to make sure it
works.
All right. So, the first version works,
but of course, the real test is to get
it to actually compose some really
insane music. So next I wrote, "Show a
powerful, expressive 32 bar piano opus
rich in complexity capturing the final
performance of a master pianist." And
then afterwards, here's my result. Let's
play this. Actually, you can't really
see this. Let me actually zoom out a bit
so you can see all the notes. And then
let's play this.
That was actually really good.
Everything sounds like pretty
harmonious. There's no dissonance
involved here. I tried the same test
with another state-of-the-art model
called JLM5, and it's a lot more
incoherent. So, this one actually sounds
really good. It has some inherent music
composition knowledge built into it. All
right. Next, let's test how good it is
at lighting physics. So here I'm getting
it to develop this simulation featuring
three metallic spheres because two
spheres is already too easy. We have
some other AI models that can already do
this. And then it's going to be
suspended above a street scene. Use any
publicly available 3D street view and
allow adjustable parameters such as
reflectivity, roughness, and other
material properties. Let's see what it
generates. All right, so here's my first
result. And the real test here is to see
if the spheres are actually reflected
within each other. So for the first
iteration, it did not get this correct.
So I put the spheres don't reflect in
each other. And then afterwards, here is
the final iteration. And as you can see,
the spheres are indeed reflected within
each other. So let's test out each
sphere to make sure everything works.
For this gold sphere, let's play around
with the reflectivity. So that works.
Let's also do roughness. So roughness
also works. And then reflection
brightness. That also works. We can also
change the color. So let's change this
to blue for example, that also works.
And then let's play with this chrome one
in the middle. So reflectivity of this
also works. Roughness also works. And
notice that as I change the roughness,
the reflections of this in the other
spheres also change. And then
afterwards, let's also play with
reflection brightness. And that also
works. Very nice. And then finally,
let's play with the red metallic sphere
to make sure that one works as well. And
yes, all the settings do work. So, in
just two prompts, I made this fully
functional, you know, floating sphere
simulation where I can change all these
different parameters and it looks great.
Now, here are some really cool use cases
of Gemini 3.1 Pro. I can upload a ton of
these receipts and then ask it to parse
all these receipts and add them to a
spreadsheet with these columns: date,
item, total, and currency. Let's press
run. All right. And here's what I got.
Indeed, it has given me all these items
and the currency is correct. And it even
got the one trick receipt that was in
Canadian instead of HKD. Very
impressive. And then afterwards, we can
click on export to sheets. And if I open
this up, here is the result. Very nice.
Now, because this can analyze images,
let's input this where's Waldo photo and
ask it to find and circle Waldo in this
photo. And yes, I'm going to use the pro
mode and then press run. Now,
unfortunately, this was a very
disappointing answer. It says that he's
not actually in this picture, which is
wrong. He is in the picture. So, that's
disappointing. And this is a classic
hallucination example where it's just
making this up. It got it completely
wrong. Now, the really awesome thing
about Gemini 3.1 is not only can it
analyze images, but also video and
audio. So, what I'm going to do first is
upload this explainer video of an
earthquake simulation for Japan and then
ask it to create an app based on this
video. Let me play you the video first.
I want you to create an interactive
earthquake visualization of Japan. So,
let's say we have a map of Japan like
this. First, I want you to list or show
me all the major cities in Japan on the
map. And then there's going to be a left
sidebar where I can adjust various
settings like earthquake, magnitude,
etc., etc. So, these are the settings
that I can adjust. And whenever I click
somewhere on the map, so let's say I
click here, then you would start to
create an earthquake. So it's going to
be an animation effect that slowly
ripples and ripples all the way until it
hits one of these cities. And based on
the magnitude of the earthquake, I want
you to calculate how severe the impact
would be for each major city. So note
that in my prompt, I did not specify
with text any details of the app. I
didn't specify Japan or earthquakes or
anything like that. It needs to figure
out everything by itself from actually
watching the video. Let's press run and
see what it generates. All right, and
here is what I got. How cool is that?
Let's actually see if this works. I can
click anywhere on the map to trigger a
simulated earthquake. So, let's click on
here. And here we go. Notice that it
even like automatically pulled up a map
of Japan for me. Next, let's increase
the magnitude of this. Very nice. Let's
make the magnitude lighter. And you can
see that doesn't really affect any of
the major cities. Let's increase this to
a whopping magnitude of 9. And then
let's set it somewhere over here. And
here is what happens. How cool is that?
So indeed, it followed exactly what I
specified from my video. Really cool.
Speaking of Google's Gemini, if you find
yourself spending hours manually
researching topics but only scratching
the surface, I've got something that
will completely transform how you
approach research and information
gathering. Take a look at how to do 10
hours of research in 20 minutes. The
marketer's guide to Google Gemini and
Notebook LM by HubSpot. I put it in the
description below for you to download
for free. This guide will help you
become a top 10% expert in any topic in
days instead of months by leveraging AI
research tools that compress what used
to take hours into just minutes of work.
You'll be able to process more sources
than your entire team and spot patterns
across information that humans typically
miss. Inside, you'll find step-by-step
instructions for using Gemini's deep
research capability to gather
comprehensive information from dozens of
sources, plus how to use Notebook LM to
transform that raw data into actionable
intelligence through AI powered
summaries and even personalized audio
overviews. My favorite section is where
they outline 11 practical applications
for this research stack, including
everything from content creation to
competitive intelligence and crisis
communication planning. The examples
show exactly how to implement these
tools in real marketing scenarios. This
resource was made by HubSpot, who's
sponsoring this video, and download it
for free via the link in the description
below. All right, here's another
example. You can easily get this to
create personalized educational content
for you or your kids. For example, let's
get it to make a fun educational course
on chemistry for kids consisting of
multiple lessons. Include real images
and interactive visual exercises. All
right, here is what we got. So, it
included three lessons and it does use
real images. Let's start the first
lesson. So, here we need to add some
hydrogen and oxygen to build a water
molecule. So, let me do this really
quickly. And here we go. Here is a water
molecule created. So everything is very
smooth. The animation is very seamless.
Next, let's try the next lesson, which
is solid, liquid, gas. Here, it failed
to load the image. And then here, we
need to select the appropriate state of
matter. So, let me just randomly fill
this out. And that works. And then
finally, the next lesson is on crazy
reactions. So, let's mix some
ingredients in the beaker. And here's
what happens. Let's click mix again.
This time let's mix vinegar with dish
soap. And nothing happened. And then
let's try dish soap and food color. You
get magical colorful bubbles. So that's
just one quick example. This is just
from one prompt, but of course you can
prompt it further to make more lessons
or make things more detailed for
whatever you want to learn. All right,
next let's see how good it is at coding
up games. So I'm going to write make a
2D platformer game similar to Super
Mario. Make it look amazing. Put
everything in a standalone HTML file.
Use publicly available assets, models,
and effects for the game. All right, and
here's what I got. Let's press start
game. And you know, this looks really
similar to Super Mario. It even has
sound effects. What happens if I fall
down here? And I do get a game over. So
everything works as expected. So, you
know, in just one prompt, it can create
a fully functional 2D platformer game
with enemies, with coin collection, with
sound effects, and of course, I can
prompt it further to add multiple levels
or to customize how the game works. Now,
as I'll talk about in a second, Gemini
3.1 is incredibly good at scientific
knowledge and reasoning. So, here's a
medical example. Analyze the molecular
pathology of distrophen loss in this
muscular distrophe. Compare therapies.
Evaluate long-term functional outcomes
from recent trials. Include nice tables
and charts. And this time, I'm going to
turn off canvas. And let's just press
run and see what it gives us. And here
is what I got. So here it gives me the
molecular pathology of this distrophen
loss etc etc and then here is a
comparative analysis of DMD therapies
with a very nice and thorough table
jam-packed with information. You can
even export this to sheets. And then
here we have some long-term functional
outcomes. What I like about Gemini 3.1
is it's quite concise. There's no BS.
There's no filler stuff. It just answers
my question very directly and gives me
the information that I need. And then
here's another table visualizing the
functional divergence. You can also
export this to Sheets. And that's pretty
much it. So very short and concise.
There's no correct answer to this. Every
top AI model out there can help you, you
know, synthesize information. So it
really depends on what vibe you're
looking for. It seems like Gemini 3.1 is
a lot more concise, whereas some other
AI models are a lot more detailed and
thorough. So those are some of my quick
demos. Next, here are some specs on
Gemini 3 Pro. As you can see here, it
can take in text, images, audio, and
video. Plus, it has a context window of
up to a million tokens. This is
basically how much information you can
fit into your prompt at once. And Gemini
has by far the widest window of a
million tokens, which is roughly 700,000
words or a medium-sized codebase or over
an hour of video. Many of the other top
AI models have a much smaller context
window. And then here it says the
architecture of 3.1 is based on Gemini
3. This is just like a marginal
improvement. It's nothing huge. And then
here it says, "Currently, you can access
this via the Gemini app, which is where
I showed you most of my demos in this
video. Plus, you can also already access
it in Notebook LM, which is a really
helpful platform for you to learn things
and generate study notes. And then for
developers, this is also available via
Google's AI studio, Gemini CLI, as well
as Google's IDE, which is called
Anti-gravity, which is very similar to
Cursor, but it's just powered by Gemini.
And then it's also available in Android
Studio and these other enterprise
platforms. Next, let's look at how good
this actually is. So, here are some
benchmarks here. They're comparing it
with the top models out there, including
Opus 4.6, Thinking Max, plus GPT 5.2X.
to extra high plus GBT 5.3 codeex extra
high. But as you can see across most of
these benchmarks, Gemini 3.1 Pro is just
better. So for humanity's last exam, it
scored the highest without any tool use.
This is a benchmark that tests an AI's
knowledge on some really obscure stuff.
For example, here are like a few sample
questions from this humanity's last exam
benchmark. Most people won't know the
answer to this. It's some really deep
and obscure scientific knowledge. But as
you can see, Gemini 3.1 Pro without any
tool use, without, you know, doing web
search or anything like that, scored by
far the highest. So, this has a lot of
world knowledge jam-packed into it. And
then for Arc AGI 2, this is a crazy
lead. I don't think this table does it
justice. So, here's another table of the
ARC AGI 2 leaderboard for your
reference. And the Y-axis is the score
or how good it is. You can see Gemini
3.1 Pro is all the way up here, even
beating Opus 4.6, six, which is covered
by this label. It's like somewhere over
here. And then the rest of the models
are just like way down here. Now, why is
this so important? If you're not
familiar with the ARC AGI2 benchmark,
this is basically how good an AI is at
solving visual puzzles. But it's more
than that. So, here are some examples.
It's first given a question answer pair.
For example, here the correct answer is
all the blue squares should gravitate to
the left, whereas all the red squares
should gravitate to the right like this.
and then it's given a new question and
it needs to figure out the answer from
this pattern. Now, this isn't just about
solving visual puzzles because for an AI
model, it can't really learn new things.
So, after training its configuration of
weights and parameters are fixed, so
it's really hard for an AI model to
actually learn and absorb new patterns
and then apply it to its answers like
this. And that's why most models rank
pretty poorly on this benchmark. But as
you can see, GPT3.1
scored all the way up here. So it seems
like it has some emergent ability to
actually learn and absorb new patterns
that it has never seen before in its
training data. In addition, it just
absolutely dominated this GPQA diamond
benchmark. This is like graduate level
scientific knowledge. It's also
incredibly good at terminal bench and
other agent coding benchmarks. And it's
also really good at long context
performance. In other words, if you feed
it a ton of stuff up to like 700,000
words, it's still able to analyze
everything and give you the information
you're looking for very accurately. Now,
these are just some of their
self-reported benchmarks. Next, let's
look at some independent evaluators as
well. So, here's an independent
leaderboard, and as you can see, Gemini
3.1 Pro is by far the most intelligent
model according to their intelligence
index. It far surpasses Opus 4.6 6 max
as well as GPT 5.2 extra high, making it
currently the best model out there you
can use. Not only that, but it's also
very costefficient. So even though it's
smarter than Claude Opus or GPT 5.2 or
Gro 4, notice that it's even cheaper in
price, making it the most performant and
the most costefficient closed model out
there. Now, interestingly, if you look
at this other leaderboard called LM
Marina, then Gemini 3.1 Pro does not
perform as well as Opus 4.6 in terms of
text. And then in terms of coding, it's
actually ranked all the way down here,
even below GPT 5.2. Same with Vision. It
even underperforms the previous Gemini 3
Pro. So, I'm getting some mixed results
between different leaderboards. And
that's why it's important to look at
multiple leaderboards to get a good
sense of how good a model actually is.
for other leaderboards like Swebench and
Livebench. Unfortunately, they haven't
released Gemini 3.1 Pro yet at the time
of this recording. But, you know,
another really awesome feature about
Gemini 3.1 is that it has a really low
hallucination rate. So, here is the
artificial intelligence omniscience
hallucination rate. And as you can see,
Gemini 3.1 hallucinates way less than
some of the other top models out there
like Claude Opus 4.6 6 as well as GBT
5.2. So, it's less likely to make stuff
up and give you the wrong answer.
Although, this still happens like a
certain percentage of the time. If you
do want a model with the lowest
hallucination rate, then the best one to
use is the open- source GLM5, which was
released last week. This is really good.
One thing to note is that this score of
50% does not mean it hallucinates 50% of
the time. This just means it got 50%
wrong on this benchmark. All right, so
that sums up my review of Gemini 3.1
Pro. This is currently one of the most
intelligent and performant models that
you can use right now, and it's already
available in the Gemini app. So, try it
out and let me know what you think of
it. As always, I will be on the lookout
for the top AI news and tools to share
with you. So, if you enjoyed this video,
remember to like, share, subscribe, and
stay tuned for more content. Also,
there's just so much happening in the
world of AI every week. I can't possibly
cover everything on my YouTube channel.
So, to really stay up to date with all
that's going on in AI, be sure to
subscribe to my free weekly newsletter.
The link to that will be in the
description below. Thanks for watching
and I'll see you in the next one.